est ce que vous appelez le nom de votre
premier amour
seddiqi oui c'était lucy lucy comme en
plus il brosse est non lucie blanc la
salle a fit papy brossard le procès si
procès ouais ouais c'est quand il
s'appelait s'appelait jean pierre la
peur si tu nous regardes dollars ou 86
cents à la vie mondaine juste ses
pédales et notre âge exemplaire mais
c'est sa part il s'appelait comment
gustave mais non mais je crois qu'il
avait le prénom de son grand-père et
s'appelait jean de serres comment il
s'appelait vous à la belle bah ouais à
laval comme un label duval et bats la
pauvre la plein c'est vrai vous delphine
à la maternelle
il s'appelait kevin away déjà bah oui le
plus tout premier chérissez wivine gavin
je ne sais même plus qu'à prier et
alexandre par terre on va pas faire tout
merci oui
pauline mais elle m'a mis en avant à
l'époque n'ont cependant avec ce même en
fait on parlait c'était l'époque des
tchats avec arme et on avait parlé
pendant des mois on était amoureux et un
jour je l'avais ans a rencontré j'avais
essayé d'embrasser ennemi avant elle m'a
dit tu étais trop gros ne peut pas
l'avenir il y avait 13 ans quelques
audaces et qui comme isabelle ne dit pas
son nom pasqualin chum sont pauline bat
pauline bof c'est quoi balayer les passe
à côté de da franchement avec une peau
magnifique
vous avez un épiderme vraiment à faire
pas dire aux îlots paul arthur arthur
arthur arthur un autre elle a d'autres
mais la panne est sympa tu absolument
patricia choron et 6ème écoute quelqu'un
me recontacte beaucoup c'était la
première de tous magnifiques sauf
qu'elle faisait elle était immense
j'étais tout petit mais j'ai eu beaucoup
de bonheur avec la tricia champions et
c'est bien là ce soir
quand est-ce qu'elle était très sympa
j'espère elle est élève match que vous
n'en étaient plus âgés que moi
bon vous il s'appelait bambine avait des
taches de rousseur un appareil dentaire
et et un compte ici
non c'est pas vrai c'était on parle même
pas du premier animal ou par mail avec
et héron le bras tant pis si j bambi est
ce que vous vous êtes déjà entraîné vous
embrassez moi je me rappelle oui j'ai
une m'appelle centre avec un couteau
non mais un couteau à pain non plus tôt
aussi j'ai pas mangé de pamecas il
s'appelle we avec amour armes dans ses
rangs ouais c'est à dire vous mettiez
devant le miroir delphine moi il me
semble que quand j'étais petit j'avais
une fois essayé comme ça avec le point
quoi
voici quelques points comme as a way we
comme ça c'est une cavité quoi par
quelle race rare technique en fait c'est
ça c'est de faire comme ça il met sa et
de mettre son doigt
non c'est une technique de la wii quand
on était plus jeunes on faisait comme ça
avec les copines meilleur il ya des mecs
aurait dû s'entraîner insurgés gagnent à
des médias embrasse très mal c'est qu'on
y croise bien alors alors ben je vais
déjà
moi j'avais connu quelqu'un à chaque
fois dès qu'ils finissent et d'embrasser
il
mais qui faisait de me laver sans aller
toute chaude et il s'en mêle la salade
césar vous êtes en tête du groupe d le
caracal il vous a des carcasses et qu'il
réponde des courses mais j'aime bien
mettre sa langue très profondément
c'est le pyromane il a tous les défauts
je me suis entraîné devant la glace
quand j'étais jeune on est dans des
années c'est après quand j'ai commencé
et ben j'aime bien la mettre très
profond je suis pas toute une écoute qui
commence 6 comment s'appelle comme ça et
après hop c'est vachement sexy mais non